like I'm 38 you know I mean I'm kind of
a late bloomer so I'm kind of maybe like
32 really but I'm also like an old soul
so I guess I'm actually like I'm back at
38 but it's a quick trip yeah yeah but
you know I grew up in a time like you
know a lot of our fathers and my friends
fathers like you know they got divorces
they went for like younger women or they
you know they gave in to this idea that
they could have it all you know uh you
know I I saw my mother not you know have
to work hard and not get a kiss on her
forehead before bed you know like she
always had to be the one giving out any
affection in her house um you know I
noticed that you know there's a lot of
men my age who it's not about the fight
there's nothing for us to do you can't
reprimand your children anymore it's an
you can't fight anymore it's more about
lawyers it's like I just feel like
there's a lot of men arriving at a point
in their lives with like what is it is
there any value in me even being a man
hmm
and like our fathers were in Wars and
our fathers were in military and there
was some you know there was a I was an
American or but I feel like there's this
aimless kind of there's a lot of men
wandering around aimlessly a lot of
confusion to because but they're
listening to you mm-hmm
yeah well men they're finding you yes
and like it's like you're like this cool
step there that showed up that actually
like cares about our mom or something
like not to put a pressure on you no no
that's a good one but I'm good one I'm
noticing from some of my like esteemed
friends feet men that are way smarter
than me and when men that have bigger
hearts than me and they're reaching out
to me they're so excited like oh you
have Jordan coming in today you know he
touches me like I they feel connection
yeah well I actually would I'm actually
as I said I'm actually thrilled and when
you know and all sorts of people are
coming up to me after the talks and on
the streets and so forth and saying you
know a fair number of them are our guys
often younger but not always and you
know they want to come up and tell me
something good that they've done and I'm
thrilled about it's like good man get
out there kill it yeah and the idea like
because part of what's happened in the
dialogue in our culture is that
masculine
responsibilities the the willingness to
shoulder responsibility which is part of
what factors into achievement and
ambition it's really the relief the part
of it that's alright positive is being
confused with tyranny and oppression and
so that men are in in large part being
punished for their for their best
impulses right you want to get out there
and like do something while doing things
wrecks the earth right it's like well
the earth is recognized so it's only
just that we you know that we defend
ourselves a little bit and it's also
just wrong is like doubt that
willingness to go out there and contend
with the world to go on your adventure
right and to take the risks and to the
entrepreneurial risks and the risks of
discipline and risks of responsibility
and to and to buttress and support the
family system and the community system
that's all incredibly laudable but for
me it's more than that because I think
of it as a bulwark against hell and I
mean I mean that both literally and
metaphorically it's like it's actually
vital that you take your place in the
world and you find a meaningful
responsible path forward because it's in
that pathway that you find the meaning
in your life and that buttresses you
against the catastrophe of life and if
you have if you don't have that you have
the aimlessness and the suffering and
the pointlessness and your own
malevolence and bitterness it's it's
hell yeah and then you make hell for you
and you make hell for your family and
you make hell for the community it's
like none of that's good and so whenever
I see people step away from that they're
moving forward and they're telling me
about it I think and I really think
great that's a miracle man keep it up
like it's really important and I don't
care what you're doing you know and I
have lots of respect for working-class
guys I mean I came from a little town
I've had all sorts of working-class jobs
you know I worked on a I worked as a
short-order cook and I worked as a
bartender in a rough cowboy bar a couple
of them I worked as a drill bit read
temper and I gas jockey Anna and I
worked on a rail crew put in line put
railway lines through and worked as a
beekeeper and and then plywood mill lots
and lots of jobs like that yeah you know
and I've renovated houses and and so
I've worked with lots of contractors and
so forth and I like I think
working-class guys the whole bloody
world rests on their shoulders it really
matters
they do a good job and so a lot of
working-class guys come to my shows and
they say look I've been listening to
your lecture as well I'm I'm doing
long-haul trucking or while I'm working
in my forklift whatever I think great
man get the hell out and do your job
properly heal it you bet and do it right
support your family man the hell up live
a responsible life and and what you're
doing is valuable I don't care what
anyone else has to say thank you guys
for checking out this clip and if you
want to see another clip then you can
look at this clip or this clip either
one of these so did you pick one or he's
still just watching me do this cuz this
is alarming